[Music]
et is breaking down the grammys of
biggest performances
[Music]
[Applause]
adèle opened the show then the weekend
and adaptive Punk have got the crowd
going
edit Sheeran it killed it I'm in love
with your body
Keith Urban and Carrie Underwood rocked
their duet
so did Alicia Keys and Maren Morris
[Applause]
and Kelsea Ballerini and Lucas graves
mash up was everything
Beyonce and Bruno Mars blew us away
shoot me stop
[Music]
stroke ambition chance the rapper
crushed it
you don't want no problem on her Kevin
Anderson pack and A Tribe Called Quest
gave us a performance to remember all
you bad folks you must go
Sturgill Simpson impressed
and Little Big Town covered Katy Perry
you and Dad will be young forever before
Katy delivered her new single
[Music]
Pentatonix brought us their version of
this classic while William Bell and Gary
Clark jr. gave fans some soul it's a
woman for bad luck you know I wouldn't
have no mother home
[Music]
demi lovato went full 70s glam to
deliver a stellar Bee Gees tribute with
Little Big Town Andra day and Kelly
[Music]
[Applause]
and Lady Gaga and Metallica brought us
home powering through some sound issues
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you